abone ol
e
[Müzik]
Herkese merhabalar ben biraz Kazan
teolojiye giden yol çizdim ve görsel
orada dönsün istedim
çünkü hep söylediğimde olay vardır bir
şeyi seviyorsanız bir şey istiyorsanız
ve o yolda Size hiçbir engel olamaz yani
başarılı her zaman açıktır sizler için
Benim Hikayem çameli'nin bir daha
köyünde başladı
1964 yılında doğdum annem babam okuma
yazma bilmez babam sonradan hep
anlatırdı rahmetli işte bir hafta okula
gitmiş okumayı öğrenmiş Yazmayı öğrenmiş
ama bir el yazısı yazar ki sayfanın
başına başladığında kalemi sonunda
bitirir Tekmen okuyabilirim
Evet şimdi
gerçekten
İlkokulu
1'ler 2'ler 3'ler 4'ler 5'ler in olduğu
tek bir sınıfta okuduğumdan onu çok
büyük avantajını gördüm gerçekten çünkü
sesli ve sessiz dersler vardın kırmızı
ve mavi yapardın öğretmen o dersleri siz
diğer derslerde Dilediğiniz hep çok
büyük bir avantaj lan bu diğer bir
avantajı ise özellikle 3. sınıfa
geldiğinde öğretmeni çok al hastalığı
vardı Oha giderdi Sonra sınıfta ben ders
verirdim öyle bir avantajla başladım
Şu tabi benim Çameli ilçesi ve Gürsu
köyü Toros darlandım Baksı ve hemen 25
kilometre çemberiyle
köyün arasında hemen arkasında Fethi
zaten öyle bir yerden Ben doğdum
şimdi İlkokulu bitirdim
Ha bir de çobanlık yaptım Baktım ki
Çoban demiş sakat Ondan sonra bir gün
Cuma cuma pazarlanır mükemmel de herkes
cumaya gelir tüm köyler 25 tane köyü
vardır şamarın da ve orada herkes
alışveriş yapar bir cuma Ben de geldim
cemaline kayıt zamanıydı Kemal Ortaokulu
için tabi Kayıt yaptıracağım da birini
bulmam lazım Her şeyden önce bir kapıyı
çaldım hemen ortaokulun yakın tarafında
iç unutmam Eğer salsa buradan çok
selamlarımı iletiyorum Vefat etmişse
Allah rahmet eylesin Ali harika Ali
Erkan diye bir Babacan birisi bana
Birlik yap onun sayesinde kaydoldum
ortaokula sonra iki yıl Çameli
Ortaokulunda okudu Ondan sonra Denizli
Merkez Ortaokulu'na geldi Tabii ki Kemal
Ortaokulunda okudum 1938'de bizim köye
Elektrik geldi bana 30 kişi var işte
elektrik sistemini kuracak ekipte bir
aşçı aranıyor bu sonra aşçı bulunamadı
Köyde çok küçük bir köyde Bizim Köy
sonra ben aşçılık yaptım orada bana 30
kişi aşçılık yaptım da ya da bir
ayakçılık yaptım masal aşçılık yaptım 2
dolu fasulye yani dolu ve bizim orada
bir zeytinyağı tenekesi 1 dolu olarak
kabul edilir genel olarak iki dolu
fasulyeye Ben muhtar Bana taahhüt ettiği
iki doğru fasulye ve aşçılık yaptım
bu sabah öğlen akşam Tabii bu şekilde
sonra Denizli'ye geldim Denizlide
Denizli sesinden okuduğu mezun oldum Her
Ondan sonra bizim Tabii bizim
zamanımızda öyle Dershane falan yoktu
Yani bizim zamanımız dediğimde çok
milattan önce bir zaman değil yani ben
57/7 yaşında olduğum düşündüğümüzde
Denizli'de Özellikle de benizli sesi o
zamanlar Fen Lisesi gibi bilseydi Her
şeyden önce be çok dershane yoktu
öğretmenlerimiz hocalarımız hafta
sonları ders verirler böyle gönüllü
dersleri verdim 3. sınıfta ben hadi iki
aşamalı sınav başladı ilk kez bizim
zamanımızda orada birinci aşamayı
geçtikten sonra çok az ye be sınav
oluyordu ben ikinci sınava İstanbul'da
girdim burada köycü Tire sanat tarihi
yazıyor hep o zaman bize çok rehberlik
yapan da o da herhalde dedim ben kendi
kendime kitlama vermiyor burada dedim
orayı yaz oy Bebeğimin arkeoloji macera
Selçuk Üniversitesi'nde bu şekilde
başladı
1982'de 86 da mezun oldum şimdi Tabii ki
üniversite yıllarımıza da köyden geldik
ya Ha bir de Çameli anlatalım çameliden
hafta sonu köye gidersiniz 25 kilometre
tek bir dolmuş vardır 34 Köyü dolaşır
tabi dolmuş parasını verip vermek mi
tercihiniz yoksa bir gazoz Denizli'nin
meşhur Zafer gazozu vardır bir gazoz ile
bir post mu yemeniz ağır basan over
basardım 25 kilometre yürüyerek köye
giderdik Yani öyle bir sistem Hadi
arkeolojide 86 yılında mezun oldum
sınava girdim O sırada hemen
87 yılında yüksek lisansa başladım ve ve
Adıyaman müzesine ve uzman olarak
atandım bu Adıyaman Müzesi'nde beş yıl
çalıştım ve onun arkasından büyük bir
torpille öyle diyelim artık denizde
denizde geleceğiz ya denize gelmek
istiyoruz 92 yılda Denizli'ye geldi
92m denizde müzede çalışmaya başladım
Tabii yüksek kısası bitirmiştim o
sıralarda
Denizli'den periyodik olarak müze
uzmanları bu örenyerlerine denetler Ben
bugün şey geldim
laodikya antik kentine geldim ve oradan
kendi kalmalıyım dedim bu kalmalıyım
dedim Ama doktora yapmam lazım Sonra
hocam aradım O gün kafesi bir sormuş
doktora için müracaat Ben gece hemen çok
hızlı bir şekilde Konya'ya gittim orada
doktora sınavına girdim ben doktora Hem
bu müzede çalışmalarımı sürdürdüm hem de
doktora çalışmama devam et dedim ha
büyük müziğe geldiğimizde şöyle bir olay
vardı yeni gelen bir uzman her yere
gönderilmesi gereken bir uzmandır Benim
hiçbir gönderdiler Afyon Müzesi soyulmuş
to onu sayımına kırk günde Ben bir Afyon
müjdesini Saydım ama Zehra kışın da o
kadar soğuktu Afyon hiç pazar günü daha
elinize ben çıkmadan müzeyi saydık ama
ondan çok şey öğrendim
Burada hep yere poliste çalıştım
Özellikle de yere polis
akropolü'nde yani mezarlık alanında
çalıştım ve doktora bitirdikten sonra bu
burada arkeoloji bölümünü
kurduk
verdi ölçümünü burada çok önemli
olduğunu düşündüm çünkü bu benim Vizyon
olması gerekli diye düşündüm ve bunun
arkasından işte 2002 yılında Doçent
olduktan sonra lake almamız gerekiyor
ama loading ya da İtalyanlar yüzey
araştırması yapıyor on yıldan bu yana
yani o zaman bir genel müdür vardı
mutlaka italyanlara vermek istiyorum
öyle bir durum var bizdenizle Hep
seferber oldu işte o esnada Benim
rahmetli Esat sivri ile ve Cengiz Bektaş
da yolum kesişti ve bunlar öncülük
yaparak Özellikle de Lavabodaki antik
kenti'nin bir yerel Üniversitesi'nin
üniversite üniversitenin alması yoluna
Gittik ama 3-4 defa beş defa Ankara'ya
gittik var Sonunda ilk kez 2002 yılında
müze denetiminde
evet hadi yaptık Pamukkale Üniversitesi
olarak Bak işte 2003 yılında bakanlar
kurulu kararı bırak kazıya başladık Ve
ve şu anda 21 21 yıl itibariyle
sürdürüyoruz şimdi Tabii ki arkeolojiye
giden yolda bize şunu söyledik arkeoloji
imkansız yoktur Sadece zaman alır Yani
bunun içinde özverili çalışılması
gerekli bir meslektir ve ben her zaman
söyledim Küçüklerle aynı düzeydedir
Çünkü usta-çırak ilişkisine çok önem
verilen bir meslektir yani birebir
yerinde öğrenerek yaşayarak algılayarak
Mesleğinizi yapması gerekecektir Tabii
Denizle birlikte hareket diyorduk ya da
ve
gerçekten sivil toplum örgütleriyle
odalarla
valiliğimiz de zaten üniversite olarak
kazı yapıyorduk belediyelerimiz ile
birlikte hareket ettik ve PES 2008
yılından itibaren
ilk kez 12 ay üzerinden sistematik
kurumsal arkeolojinin olmasını test
ettik yad2 antik kentinde Tabi o zaman
hep şu vardır Ben burada hemen hemen
Denizli'de
sanayicilerimizin işadamlarını çoğunu
alırım Çok teşekkür ederim Gerçekten
bugün 4'ün ekiplerle ülkede çok güzel
bir gezi yaptık Tabi biz özellikle de
Esat sivri Rahmetlik şunu söylerdim bak
hoca verdim bir şey parasız olacak
mekanı olacak beleş olacak Yani bunu
mutlaka sağlamalıyız Yazık yani kendi
için derdim sonra bir sistem kurduk Biz
valilikte bir hesap açıldı işte orada
işadamlarımız gönlünden geçtiği şekliyle
buraya belli bir katlı yapılar ve ondan
sonra bak bu kazı gerçekten 2008
yılından itibaren on Emsal bir kazı
haline gel bu ve devletimizin politikası
haline geldi ki Bugün
2019yılı itibarıyla da birçok kadının 12
üzerinden yapılması ve kurumsal yönde
kaza olması yönünde bir sistemin yolunu
açtık diye ben düşünüyorum lahutiye
kadınlar olarak tabi biz bizim için çok
önemli bir olay vardı üniversitemiz Her
zaman arkamızda Aydın ve üniversitemizle
kazı alanı çok yakındım ve burada
öğrencilerimizin aynı zamanda yerinde
birebir öğrenmelerini sağlama yolunda
bir hareket yapmamız gerekiyordu Ve bu
şekilde de kazı çalışmalarını sürdük ben
tabi her şeyden önce şunu söylemek
istiyorum eşim her zaman yanımdaydı çok
büyük destek sağladı olmasaydı bu kadar
çok uzun süre Belki de çalışma imkanı
bulamayan bilirdim yani bunu burada
özellikle vurgulamak istiyorum Tabi bu
ve sistematik kurumsal kazılara başladı
ama bunun başka bir alt yapısında olması
gerekiyordu bu sefer ne yapalım diye
düşündüm ben Arkadaşlarla toplandık
neden su kuralım dedik ama enstitüsü'nde
bayağı uğraştık yani Dört yıldan fazla
uğraştık ve sonuçta üniversitemizde
Pamukkale üniversitemizde Türkiye'deki
ilk arkeoloji Enstitüsü'nün kurduk ve
bugün de bir saat üstü düzeyde hem
yüksek lisans ve doktora düzeyinde
gerçekten çok kaliteli eğitim veriyoruz
ve gerçekten bu bilim bilim üreten devam
ettirecek olan ve bayrağı taşıyacak olan
gençler yetiştiriyor Tabii Özellikle de
arkeolojide şöyle de olay var Siz
gittikten sonra arkanızdan gelenler
neler yapacak ve sizin bıraktığınız
bayrak daha Yükseklerde dalgalanacak mı
önemli olan buz buydu zaten şimdi Tabii
Özellikle de Türk arkeolojisi de bu çok
önemli bir yerdedir Yani bizim bugün
Yahudi ya da kurduğumuz sistemle ilgili
yabancı kazı heyeti Başkanlığı'na
gelerek Bizim yaptığımız restorasyonlar
Bizim yaptığımız konservasyon lar veya
çalışmalarla ilgili bizden bilgi
alıyorlar yani istedikten sonra
yapılamayacak hiçbir şey olmadığını
Özellikle de ben vurgulamak istiyorum ki
gerçekle açık söylemek lazım benim en
önemli sevgilim leodikya Tabii ki eşim
burada çocuklarım İki çocuğum var Ve
tabii ki de unutmamak lazım Bir de Bebiş
var bir de torunum var ve Gerçekten siz
ne Mesai kavramı mız olması gerekiyor ve
insanlarla çok sıkı ilişkiler için
durmanız gerekiyor ve sevdirme niz
gerekiyor yani Özellikle de biz lo diye
kazılarında halkla insanlarımızla
birlikte olmayı tercih ettik ve
özellikle de bir yaşayan arkeoloji Parkı
yapmak istedik ki Allah bize bu güne
kadar kim gelmişse ya Bize şu anlatırsın
dediğinde hiçbir zaman kırmadık yani onu
pazar günü bile kırmadık istersen ve
belli bir yere geldiğini düşünüyoruz
öyle canım onu hep birlikte yaptım
denizlerle birlikte yaptık Kültür ve
Turizm bakanlığımız da yaptık
valiliğimiz de yaptık belediyelerimiz ve
sivil toplum örgütlerimiz de
odalarımızda yaptık üniversite olarak
biz gerçekten burada yerel bir
birlikteliğin önemini ortaya koyduk ve
bunu başardığımızı ben açıkçası
düşünüyorum Tabi bu günler Türkiye'de
gerçekten 2013 yılında UNESCO nun dünya
geçici kültür mirası listesi içine
alınmasını sağladık ve yaptığımız
çalışmalardan dolayı çok önemli bir
kurum Europa noska ödül aldık Denizli
Büyükşehir belediyemizde yaptığımız bir
çalışmamızda Bu da bizi Türk arkebüs
adına gerçekten çok ü çok sıcak bir yere
gelmeyi ve Bu başarının da hep birlikte
bizim başarımız olduğunu
vurgulamak için özellikle söylüyorum
şimdi son zamanlarda bir tiyatro iki
tane tiyatrolar Çünkü Batı Tiyatrosu ve
iki buçuk yılda 96 metre çapındaki bir
tiyatronun Dünya kültürlerinin
üstünde diyebileceğimiz yüzde 97
orijinal olması kaydıyla restorasyonunu
yaptık ayağa kaldırdık Gerçekten bu da
çok önemli diye ben düşünüyorum her
zaman özellikle vurguladığı mı söz
vardır gelecekte geçmişte yaptığımız
güzel şeylerle anılan Alacağız biz de
gerçekten üniversite olarak Pamukkale
Üniversitesi olarak gelecekte güzel
başarılarla hep anılmak istediğimizden
dolayı da da Haftanın yedi günü Biraz
önce söylediğim şekilde laodikya antik
kentinde çalışmalarımız sürdürüyoruz tüm
ekip olarak E tabii gerçekten gençlere
ben şunu söylüyorum Her zaman tabi bazen
derler işte arkeoloji ben hiçbir yere
kazanamıyorsan işte bir yerde arkeoloji
yaz orada okursun üniversite mezun
olursun diye değil aslında arkeoloji çok
önemli bir bilim dalı yani geçmişte
yaşayan insanların bıraktıkları somut
verileri incelediği için o bilim dalının
içinde her şey var yani Edebiyattan
tutumda
bunun yanında kıskan tutunda Mimarlar
Mühendisler varıncaya kadar Kent
planlamasında varıncaya kadar çok önemli
Arkeoloji ve bizim Özellikle de
bulunduğumuz Denizli coğrafyası turizm
bakımından özellikle ve Kültür turizmi
bakımından çok önemlidir lokalizasyonu
söz konusu ve biz de ekibi olarak
üniversite olarak Pamukkale Üniversitesi
çalışanları olarak lo diye belki
yaptığımız çalışmaların Hem ülkemiz
ekonomisine hem de özellikle de
ülkemizin o Nur olmasına çok büyük
katkılar yaptığını düşünüyorum şimdi
Tabii ki çok konu var çok önemli
Başımızdan geçen Anılar var Ve siz Tabii
ki en önemli anılarımız dan birisi de
özellikle de rahmetli valimiz Recep
yazıcıoğluyla çok fazla haşır neşir
olduk kazıda özellikle altında çünkü
yazın sıcak olduğu için Denizli altında
kazıya başlıyorsunuz rahmetli altında
kazıya gelirdim bizimle dolaşırdım yedi
buçukta kahvaltı yapardık sonra 8'de
direkt Tabii ki iş mesaide şaşırtmaz dım
direkt çalışmaya geçelim tabi bunun
yanında birçok valimiz gerçekten
başlangıçta İl Özel İdaresi tarafından
Daha sonra da özellikle değil Kop emlak
vergisi katkıları yönüyle
lake bak çalışmalarımız sürdürmemiz is
ağladım sen biz proje kadınısınız Yani
biz tamamen projeler bak bak bu projeler
çerçevesinde
çalışmalarımızı sürdürüyoruz Bu yönüyle
den Türk halkı üstüne farklı bir bakış
açısı getirdiğimizi düşünüyoruz Ve
tabiki Özellikle de 12 aylık süreç
içinde sürekli kazı ve restorasyon ların
yapılması yönüyle de Pamukkale
Üniversitesi olarak biz iki başlattık Ve
tabii ki Biraz önce de söylediğim gibi
ilk arkeoloji Enstitüsü'nün kurulması ve
burada tüm ülkemizdeki
uzman
ekipleri yetiştirilmesi yönünde önemli
bir adım atmış oluyoruz Bugün
arkadaşlarla da güzel gezdik güzel
sohbetler ettik Yani ki ya da çünkü
antik kentler arasında ölü değildir
yaşayan yerlerdir bakmasını bildiğimizde
görmesini bildiğimizde sizlere onlar
geçmişten Binlerce yıl öncesinden çok
şey anlatır çok şey aktarır ki bu ve en
önemlisi Tekstil Örneğin Çünkü çok
önemli bir Tekstil merkezi ile ikiye
antik dönemde günümüzde de bizim
denizlimize gerçekten dünya çapında
üretimlerin yapıldığını ve bunun da
Binlerce yıl öncesine dayandığını Biz
ortaya çıkarmış durumdayız ve pembe
Diğer taraftan birçok verilen bulunduğu
Örneğin Denizli horozu Bugün de hep
arkadaşlarla baktık ve bunların
Özellikle de bağlantılarını kullanarak
tanımlı olmasını sağlamak ve her şeyden
önemlisi ülkemizin ekonomisi için ve
özellikle değer bir kültür varlığının
gelecek kuşaklara aktarılması yönüyle
leodikya önemli bir
antik kenttir ve özellikle ve
arkeolojiye giden yolda Bizim yaptığımız
çalışmalarla birlikte de eserlerimizin
gelecek kuşaklara aktarılması yönünde
büyük Gayret ve bunun çabası yönüyle
çalışmalarımızı sürdürüyoruz
ne var burada özellikle şunu ben
söylemek istiyorum bir köyden çıkmış ve
buraya kadar gelmiş
çalışmış ve tam ikimizin şöyle birlikte
dezavantajı mız Vardı bizim elimizden
tutan kimse yoktu yani başkaları bir
çalışmıştı iki çalışmışsa bir çalışmışsa
Pardon biz 356 çalışmak zorundaydık o
yönüyle Hep çalıştık ve Mesleğimizi
sevdik ve bu mesleğimizin sevmenin
yanında da başkalarının bu mesleği
sevmesini algılamasını ve bu meslek
yönüyle de devamlılığın sağlanması
yönünde çabalarımız olduğunu düşünüyoruz
ve öğrencilerimiz de bu yönde
yetiştirmeye çalışıyoruz Tabi ben burada
bugün Özellikle de arkeolojinin Türk
arkeolojisinin
cumhuriyetimizle birlikte dünya çapında
bir bilim dalı olduğunu ve Her zaman
söylediğim bir olay vardır dünyanın
herhangi bir yerinde kürsüde bir tür
kartıyla konuşuyorsa o ciddi iyi
bilendir Bu da çok önemli diye
düşünüyorum ben teşekkür ediyorum
hepinizi saygıyla selamlamak istiyorum
Sağ olun